Batteries suck, you know it, I know it, we
all know it and it's the one thing everyone
on Earth can come together and sing about.
Will this new technology be the hero we deserve?
Hey friends, countrymen, battery haters, this
is DNews, I'm Trace.
A battery is typically two metals, one that
gives up electrons (called an anode), and
one that takes them (called a cathode), connected
through an electrolyte -- something that can
move the electrons around easily.
Electrolytes are usually liquids or gels,
but isn't keeping a liquid in your laptop
dangerous?
What if we could just get rid of it altogether?
Well that’s the challenge.
Because big batteries, like those in your
car, have a liquid electrolyte they require
a rigid plastic or metal casing to keep the
battery connections stable.
But most batteries you use are Lithium-ion,
where the cathode and anode are connected
using an electrolyte made of an organic gel,
called a polymer.
Polymer electrolytes can use light-weight
plastic casings, and can be made in different
sizes which is great for new electric cars
and portable devices.
But there's a problem…
Their tendency to explode.
Electrons flow from the anode to the cathode
through your device, and that's how you're
probably watching this right now.
But Lithium is highly reactive, and if the
battery casing is punctured the reaction of
lithium with the moisture in the air can cause
the gel electrolyte to catch fire…
OR as my chem teacher used to say, an "energetic
reaction.”
Also, as an added suck, lithium-Ion batteries
also don't work well in the cold, and because
the gel is organic the more times they're
used, the less charge the batteries can move.
But the future is coming!!
The lithium works great, and the electrons
are doing their job, but the gel is the problem.
So, scientists are working on a way to get
that gel OUTTA THERE.
Every battery since Alessandro Volta's original
voltaic cell of copper, zinc and a salt bridge
-- has used liquid or gel components.
But what if we could make an electrolyte that
was just a solid piece?
Research published in Nature Materials might
have done just that!
IT'S LIKE A SCIENCE MIRACLE!
Building on another paper from 2011, researchers
created a solid electrolyte that can move
the electrons just like the gel, but without
the mess of explosions, sensitivity to cold,
and, you know… gel.
They did this using a 3D tetrahedral framework
of Lithium, Germanium, Phosphorous, and Sulfur.
The framework lets electrons move through
it, hopping from one molecule to the next
for hundreds of thousands of charge cycles!
Because it's solid, you could "drive a nail
through the battery," and it won't explode
-- nice.
And surprisingly, it functioned at negative
20 fahrenheit (-29C)!
One of the researchers commented that this
design could be "almost a perfect battery,
solving most of the remaining issues [that
batteries have]*."
It's super experimental.
So far, the design is very limited and can
only produce 5 volts… the iPhone 5 battery
put out 3.8 volts.
Obviously, more research is needed.
And other papers are coming out with alternative
solid electrolytes, but this one is promising.
On top of ALL that, scientists figure, because
they don't have to accommodate a gel, they
can add MORE individual cells of power, upping
battery density by 20 to 30 percent, all while
bringing down overall cost.
Meaning these potential solid-state batteries
will be safer, cheaper and will last longer.
Sounds hot.
Lithium-Ion batteries are rechargeable because
they've been designed that way, but why aren't
all batteries rechargeable?
I've got the answer for you RIGHT HERE!
Do you hate batteries?
Want a solid state one for your phone?
Tell
the world!